moi si on me dit si bon qu'on est allé d
cardio que tu as un centre de
conditionnement pour femmes enfin maman
bébé enfin une augmentation du nombre
d'enfants par famille je trouve
on commence à avoir des doutes a mis de
plus en plus nombreuses ces paroles
ainsi abb cardio qu'on voit des familles
avec 2 3 qui après enfants rapprocher
aussi souvent donc j'imagine qu'elles
ont confiance en l'avenir où elle aime à
être maman
c'est vraiment l'accès aux garderies
vraiment c'est inquiétant on m'a fait ça
fait un an et demi que je l'espère que
je peux toujours pas de nouvelles pour
les cpe à part c'est aussi l'accès aux
médecins qui tient toujours mais qui
causeraient sur les politiciens qui fait
la part belle à blé non non je décourage
en plus toi je vois des mecs mais j'ai
l'impression de te présente qu'on se
fait voler les pique niques la largeur
sans bon train puisque après dépenser
n'importe comment par rapport à la vraie
de nom on s est rassuré inquiète
oui non c'est ce que comme son prénom
c'est un enfant qui n'est pas réglé
marco von ah que c'est un gros enjeu
pour à main avec ce qui se passait toute
accession que la prise dans mon cou à
moi pour être certain
l'environnement ce n'est pas tant qu'on
en a pas beaucoup parlé cette campagne
ici
ce qui m'inquiète le plus pour l'avenir
de mes enfants c'est la protection des
milieux nation c'est vraiment la
politique elle est basée sur le période
très courte les élections revient
souvent
moi j'aimerais avoir une gestion un peu
plus long terme
justement comporte à l'heure à dire
qu'on voit dans les aides en vingt et un
d'entre eux
donc là